près de villefranche sur saône elle
limite mâconnais beaujolais à partir du
château de fléchères les caméras de
cinéma ont envahi la région
on y tourne en effet le diable par la
queue que réalise philippe de broca
philippe de broca qu'est ce que ce
diable par la queue
c'est les mille et une façons de pour
les femmes d'attraper un bonhomme c'est
à dire que c'est une histoire qui se
passe dans un château sur des dames qui
tiennent une auberge et qui ont trouvé
l'homme l'homme qu'elles attendent pour
plusieurs raisons parce qu'il a beaucoup
d'argent d'une part et parce que mon
dieu les séduisants et bel homme et ses
quatre femmes le connivence essaye de
les seuils de le garder dans la maison
et c'est d'abord de garder son argent
purement et simplement et tout bêtement
essaye de le tuer tout ça dans l'humour
noir bien entendu il suffit comme les
brevets et puis ça passe avant que c'est
trop difficile et 17 de le séduire ce
qui est beaucoup plus simple et
effectivement il restera dans la maison
très amoureux yves montand quel est
votre rôle dans ce film c'est leur rôle
c'est le rôle d'un gangster d'un
gangster
méridionale en fait il a pu l'accent
méridional parce qu'il faut qui les
conduira jusqu'à un certain volume mais
une certaine exubérance
il aurait pu être italien il aurait pu
être l'interprète avec l'accent russe ou
même américains si on veut mais ça a été
très très difficile de faire l'accent
américain et russe et puis je pense que
ce serait donner trop une couleur qui
n'allait pas au style du film à londres
ont choisi l'accent carrément
méridionale et un exubérant
c'est un personnage comme ça avec une
apparence extrêmement dure et est assez
rébarbatives
mais dès qu'il est coincé dans des
situations précises ils se
il s'en sort par une pirouette que
j'espère assez drôle que nous espérons
tous assez drôle
le travail de l'acteur m'entendant
peuvent-ils pas le chanteur montant de
préparer son one man show dont on parle
beaucoup dans le monde du spectacle
eh bien non c'est à dire que j'avais
pris une date pour passer éventuellement
l'olympia dire l'envié prochain je
voulais préparer ça bien tranquillement
et puis il m'est arrivé ces deux trois
films à faire coup sur coup et qu'il
était difficile de reporter parce que
l'avancé des bons rôles parce qu'ensuite
c'est très bien payé
je dis très honnêtement mais surtout
aussi c'est parce que c'est des
histoires intéressantes particulièrement
z que je vais tourner on va faire la
première coproduction franco algérienne
avec costa gavras comme réalisateur et
sur un scénario sur un livre de
vasilikos et un scénario et dialogues de
gestion de promo namys automne madeleine
renaud vous jouez si la conteste c'est à
dire en fait le rôle principal le rôle
qu'est du film
or depuis le dialogue des carmélites les
sept ou huit ans vous aviez oublié le
cinéma que signifie ce retour
eh bien
ce retour c'est parce que philippe de
broca a pensé à moi
il m'a apporté ce scénario puis trouver
un sens
très bien écrit plein de sensibilité
drôlerie et il ya évidemment et
un personnage qui m'a tout de suite
contre
santé etc en effet depuis le dialogue
des carmélites j'avais été très très
gâté jusque là au cinéma
et on n'avait pas proposé le boul
qui m'attire spécialement
descola philippe de broca voilà un jeune
homme plein de talent que j'admirais et
qui me propose un scénario vraiment de
très grande qualité avec un bon rôle est
un rôle comique ce qui m'enchante maya
seul il ya bien longtemps comme vous
avez vu en france nous vous retrouvons
avec plaisir cette fois dans une comédie
ce qui est rare qu'est-ce que vous jouez
dans le diable par la queue
j'ai joué une femme qui est toujours
amoureuse un peu de l'amour même à
amoureuse et tous les hommes amoureuse
de l'amour c'est un rôle qu'il vous
plaît oui je suis fait pas partie